nope not on camera that's what I want to
give you a piece of advice stuff gets on
the internet and it doesn't go away you
hear me this is actually very saying it
to us
hi my name is Kate McKinnon I'm here
with BuzzFeed I'm going to answer some
fan questions about the upcoming
animated film leap and some other stuff
and you're gonna play with puppies while
I do it
[Music]
I'm cool and your name will be Griffith
I'm you know tough to answer questions
while there is such sweetness and
unbounded
[Music]
[Applause]
I have had only positive interactions in
relation to my impressions of people
which makes me happy because I do them
with love and I hope that the people of
who I do them of really like them isn't
that right Angela
you know it's really fun just running
around backstage when everyone's getting
changed and we've done feels like a
middle school play all over again
sometimes you see someone make
[Music]
the trick is I guess fear you don't want
to like ruin it by laughing so but I
often do we haven't spoken much John
what what is it like being so cute that
you should be eating
is it hard knowing that you should be
eating that because you're so cute
[Music]
I think point emmy-award has run away to
another continent because I have not
heard from him or her in months oh you
don't like that jacket you think that's
a bad fashion choice let's see if we can
keep this jacket I am a cool dude my
name is Rachel look at what a coup that
is you've gotta believe in yourself and
you just have to work harder at it than
you've ever worked at anything before in
your life and if you keep doing that and
keep believing in yourself um great
things that do happen you just have to
work super hard and just um if you have
a passion that's the most beautiful
thing in life and you just have to bust
out and do it baby
my passion needs to be comedy but now it
is these four puppies explicitly
[Music]
can we have lunch please can we stop and
eat we never eat have you noticed that
we're working our way drill more why can
I wipe it yep do their mouths smell like
garbage
yes do what do I want seven to kiss me
on the mouth
[Music]
that's an interesting question there is
no backstory I just like to salute and I
guess it became a thing
[Music]
my son Nino who I hope is not watching
this because he would not like to see me
wanting Overson he's doing very well
even though it's very hot in the summer
and he doesn't love that
[Music]
before before ten minutes ago it might
have been something different but now it
is swimming in fur
do you want to read the question
he's cute but he doesn't have a future
as a professional interviewer
[Music]
I think you know sometimes you don't get
to hello um you don't get to hello
oh you want to play fetch you're not in
the room with the people that you're
acting against and sometimes you've done
your parts on different days you wanna
do you wanna um crisabel your Rufus so
sometimes you don't get to see or who
you're acting against
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness Maddie Ziegler is the
most amazing dancer I've ever seen and
I'm so obsessed with her I was obsessed
with her even in common
before she did her first see a video
what are you eating
and so yes a girl Rachel I was so
excited that she was doing this because
she's I'm I'm so obsessed with her as an
artist and she's so young and it's crazy
that she's so such an amazing Olivier or
will you do me a favor Rachel I just go
into my pocket just and live in my house
how was that so
he just in conclusion all of these
fabulous little puppies are adoptable at
North Shore Animal League America which
happens to be where I got my son Nina
from and all of my childhood gets as
well
it's an incredible facility thank you so
much for lending me these friends and
would someone please take them into
their homes because Nina would get too
jealous all the puppies have left me
what does that say about me
[Music]